[Musique]
je suis intelligente je suis audacieuse
je suis sensible je suis créative et je
suis indépendante et si je le suis ce
parce qu'une femme qui a été à la fois
un père et une mère
m'enseigner ces principes
elle ne l'a pas fait seulement par des
conseils mais beaucoup plus par son vécu
une femme qui s'est retrouvé très tôt à
devoir prendre en charge toute seule ses
quatre enfants
une femme qui a dû mettre de côté bien
souvent ses ambitions et son plaisir
personnel afin de prioriser le bien-être
de ses enfants
il est important de mettre en lumière ce
sujet pas seulement parce qu'il s'agit
de ma mère mais parce que des milliers
de femmes aujourd'hui font face à cette
réalité
nous évoluons dans un monde où le nombre
de familles monoparentales
ne cesse de s'accroître et nous
emballons mais pas souvent de la
meilleure des manières
ces mères célibataires qui sont souvent
perçus comme des femmes indigne est
capable de donner une bonne éducation
d'inculquer de belles valeurs de retenir
un homme de réussir dans la sphère
professionnelle
ces femmes là qu'ils se retournent
souvent
rejetés par leur famille
empêchés d'accéder à des niveaux
supérieurs dans les entreprises
simplement parce que certaines personnes
les juges incapable d'assumer plus de
responsabilités oui trop de préjugés
qui sont maintenus par la société mais
ce qui est dommage c'est qu'ils sont
parfois aussi entretenue par le propre
enfant
ces enfants qui le jugent responsable
ou
de l'absence ou de du d-pad le paie ses
enfants qui font semblant d'ignorer tous
les efforts et qu'ils trouvent qu'elles
sont incapables de la donne est un
niveau de vie qui sont convaincus de
mériter
ces enfants qui le jugent difficile à
vivre
incapable de communiquer incapables de
se mettre à la place afin de comprendre
les émotions et le douleur
mais si la relation mère et enfant
est souvent détruites c'est parce que
ces mamans seules sans s'en rendre
compte rejette sur leurs enfants tout la
rancune qu'elle nourrisse vis-à-vis de
le paix
une rancune qui est souvent alimentée
par la honte du au regard des autres par
la solitude
et par le poids des charges qui ne cesse
de s'accroître au fil des années
et la société a une part de
responsabilité dans ce ressenti
une société qui pointe du doigt les
femmes mais qui oublie que pour fait des
enfants il faut être deux quelle ironie
où sont donc les pères
cela qu'ils sont moins juger par la
société
cela qu'ils ont le droit de se remarier
cela qu'ils
poursuivent leur carrière sans avoir à
se soucier de fait passer le bien-être
de leurs enfants à fond avant leurs
ambitions personnelles
c'est bella qui souvent refusent
d'assumer leurs responsabilités
mais qui ne subissent pas pour autant le
regard désapprobateur de là société
n'est le jugement de leurs enfants parce
que ces derniers sont trop occupés à
réclamer la présence
et je faisais partie de cette catégorie
d'enfants
et peu importe les efforts qu une mère
peut faire lorsqu'un père est absent il
ya toujours quelque chose qui manque il
ya toujours un vide qui se fait
ressentir dans le coeur du ses enfants
mais en grandissant
je me suis mise dans la peau d'une femme
et j'ai commencé à voir que ça ne devait
pas être facile
de devoir assumer des responsabilités
tout seul alors qu'on a posé un acte
avec quelqu'un
que ça ne devrait pas être facile d'être
toujours la personne qui joue le rôle de
la méchante
d'être une personne qui passe toujours
c'est lui tout seul
sans avoir personne pour vous dit que
vous faites bien les choses vous
discutez avec vous des réalités du
quotidien
pour faire face avant avec vous aux
défis qui concernent votre famille et
ses enfants que vous avez mis au monde
oui
j'ai commencé à voir qu'elle devait être
le poids le fado que mam est transporté
bien souvent
et si je ne laisse jamais vu pleurer
je suis convaincu aujourd'hui que c'est
parce que elle se disait qu'elle avait
le devoir d'être forte
et de ne pas se laisser aller devant
nous
j'ai donc compris que tout ce dont elle
avait besoin
pour soulager un peu le poids des
douleurs qu'elle transportait c'était de
l'amour
de la compréhension et beaucoup de
soutien venant de la part de ces enfants
est bien souvent c'est tout ce que ces
femmes là nous demandent de la pad le
entourage
il est donc temps que la société
changent de regard à vis à vis de ces
femmes et les voies pour ce qu'elles
sont réellement des femmes qui éduque
des femmes qui nourrissent des femmes
qui ont celle des femmes qui gardent des
femmes qui élèvent des femmes qui se
saignent des femmes qui se sacrifie en
gros des femmes qui assument leurs
responsabilités avec force détermination
et courage
elles ont le droit d'être célébrée pour
cela
elles ont le droit de connaître la joie
de foyers et pas lui
elles ont le droit de gravi les échelons
dans la société sans se soucier du qu'en
dira-t-on
parce que si je suis devenue la femme
que je suis aujourd'hui c'est parce que
j'ai été éduqué par l'une d'entre elles
et c'est bien la preuve qu'elles sont
capable d'éduquer des nations et de
laissé un bel héritage
à une mère célibataire
qui sait peut-être retrouver veut un peu
trop tôt
qui a été abandonnée ou qui est divorcée
ne considère pas cette situation comme
un handicap qui vient empêcher de
réaliser et qui vient freiner son
accomplissement
ne laisse pas cette société défi mais
qui tu es et prédit la venue de des
enfants
tu es fort et tu peux y arriver
ce n'est pas un échec
et c'est encore moins un déshonneur
que d'avoir à élever ses enfants tout
seuls c'est juste la preuve que tu as
vécu une expérience
qui cette n'a pas marché mais dont tu as
eu de relever
ne baissent la tête devant personne
redresse la tête
réajusta couronne et fonce bats toi ou
tes rêves bats toi pour tes ambitions
bats toi pour assurer l'éducation de ses
enfants et surtout bats toi pour que
demain on puisse raconter ton histoire
avec admiration
ce n'est pas encore la fin du match est
une époque ont disqualifié et je crois
en toi tu peux y arriver
[Applaudissements]